Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince says his
country will develop a nuclear bomb if
Iran builds nuclear weapons Mohammed bin
Salman made that startling statement
during our recent visit to Saudi Arabia
for this Sunday's 60 minutes it is the
first u.s. television interview with a
Saudi leader since 2005 and we asked the
32 year old Crown Prince about the
political economic and social reforms
unfolding in the kingdom
we also discussed foreign policy in
Saudi Arabia's longtime foe Iran you've
been rivals for centuries
at its heart what is this rift about is
it a battle for Islam is it
Iran is not a rival to Saudi Arabia it's
army is not among the top five armies in
the Muslim world the Saudi economy is
larger than the Iranian economy Iran is
far from being equal to Saudi Arabia but
I've seen that you called the Ayatollah
Khamenei the new Hitler of the Middle
East leadership absolutely why because
he wants to expand he wants to create
his own project in the Middle East very
much like Hitler who wanted to expand at
the time many countries around the world
and in Europe did not realize how
dangerous Hitler was until what happened
happened I don't want to see the same
events happening in the Middle East does
Saudi Arabia need nuclear weapons to
counter Iran Saudi Arabia does not want
to acquire any nuclear bomb but without
a doubt if Iran developed a nuclear bomb
we will follow suit as soon as possible
and you can see our full report with the
Saudi Crown Prince Sunday night on 60
minutes right here on CBS